[Music]
cognitive behavioral therapy is based on
the idea that certain situations trigger
false core beliefs that negatively
impact our thoughts emotions behavior
and physical reactions
once we learn how to identify what
situations bring upon such destructive
thoughts we can practice developing new
interpretations that will then change
our pattern of reaction
the therapy is widely used to help
people with phobias depression anxieties
or addictions
to show how it works let's look at lily
a teenage girl who hates going to school
due to her fear of being judged and
humiliated
in her first session the therapist tries
to build trust and explains how cbt
functions since the better lily
understands the process the more likely
it is that the therapy is effective the
therapist also illustrates how our brain
in specific situations
follows a fixed path of reason which
gets stronger after years of having the
same thought process
many of our destructive behaviors are
based on false core beliefs thoughts
that objectively don't make sense
we acquired these false beliefs when we
were too young to interpret others
correctly throughout the therapy lily
will try to unlearn these false beliefs
and create new mental pathways that will
replace the false belief she holds of
herself with more realistic thoughts
once lily understands the process the
counselor begins to ask questions
following the socratic method a form of
argumentative conversation that
stimulates critical thinking to draw out
false ideas and underlying assumptions
would you like to tell me why you're
here today starts the therapist
because i think i'm not normal lily
responds
you appear perfectly normal to me can
you be more specific
i think i'm afraid of people
so you are afraid of me
no
do you feel socially insecure
i'm not sure what you mean tell me how
you feel about school
i'm scared of going because they think
i'm stupid
throughout the interview the counselor
takes notes of lily's answers and
identifies the signs of social anxiety
based on a false core belief
lily believes she is stupid
for a homework lily should practice
introspection
the goal to find out which situations
trigger her negative thoughts
she gets a learning journal to keep
records of all triggers and other
observations such as self-talk or
interpretations of particular events and
people
during the following week lily becomes
more aware of her thoughts and the
physical reactions they trigger
by paying attention to her feelings she
identifies a specific pattern which
occurs every time during math class
the moment her teacher begins to ask
questions her heart starts racing and
her palms get sweaty she worries about
having to answer the question about
making a mistake about looking dumb in
front of all the others
[Music]
in her second session lily shares her
observations and the therapist helps her
realize that her cognitive behavioral
patterns are false first her math grades
are great so she should feel anything
but stupid second she explains that
there are always more interpretations to
the same thing what to her may look like
her stupid face to others she may just
look unhappy about having to answer
the reason she is afraid of what people
think is a form of social anxiety a
completely irrational cognitive
behavioral response
as the sessions continue the therapist
suggests three practical strategies
through journaling lily records her
negative beliefs and reformulates them
into positive ones she can replace them
with constructive self-talk helps her to
replace a critical voice with a positive
one and she starts exposure exercises
which means lily deliberately puts
herself in situations where she becomes
the center of attention
along the way the two set goals that are
specific measurable achievable realistic
and time-based
smart goals give her control over how
she progresses thus helping her gain
confidence in herself
over time and with a lot of practice her
brain builds new neural pathways that
lead to different more neutral reactions
to the same old triggers
and one day lily may even enjoy the
thrill of speaking in front of her class
her interpretation of the situation is
more realistic and more aligned with
those of the others
cbt was initially developed in 1964 by
aaron tempkin beck
beck hypothesized that people's feelings
are determined by the way they interpret
situations rather than the situations
per se
about depression he once said if our
thinking is bogged down by distorted
symbolic meanings illogical reasoning
and erroneous interpretations we become
in truth blind and deaf
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts